what I basically try to do is understand
human nature how the mind works what
makes us tick what are the patterns of
thought and emotion and motivation that
characterize our species then I focus on
language partly because you can't make a
living out of studying human nature it's
just do big the topic you've got to pick
something tractable to study for me it
is has been in language and indeed for
much of my career one little corner of
language namely regularly irregular
verbs and I have my reasons for focusing
on that particular corner I think it
does shed light on larger questions
about what makes the mind work but
language is a general topic is a I think
a good entree into human nature for a
number of reasons its distinctively
human if you're interested in general
and what makes humans unlike mice and
birds language is a pretty good place to
start not only because of language
itself the fact that we make noise with
our mouths in order to get ideas across
but because language has to be
fine-tuned for the kind of thoughts and
the kind of social relationships that
humans want to share and negotiate with
one another so it's a it's a window into
human nature it's also figured in
debates on human nature perhaps most
famously with Chomsky in the late 50s
using language as a way to rehabilitate
the idea of innate mental structure
something that was virtually taboo in
the 1950s he said language is a very
good candidate for something that is
innately and uniquely human
so it's an opening wedge for the idea
that that important parts of the mind
are innately structured it's also a
prime case of mental computation it's
very hard to make sense of language of
our ability to string words into new
combinations
sentences that other people have never
heard before but can very quickly
understand for the first time without
appealing to the idea that we have a
mental algorithm a set of rules or a
recipe or a formula that picks words out
of a memory store and strings them
together in combinations where the order
as well as the choice of words is
meaningful so language sheds light on
the idea that the mind is a
computational system
my main preoccupation today is using
languages as a window into human nature
I've studied language in the past as a
an example of human computation what are
the kinds of simple operations of lookup
in combination that the mind is capable
of how is language structured what I'm
turning to now is the interface between
language and the rest of the mind how
language can illuminate our social
relationships for example why is so much
of language use veiled or indirect or
done via innuendo rather than people
blurting out exactly what they mean why
do I say if you could pass the salt that
would be great instead of give me the
salt why does someone make a sexual
overture in terms of would you like to
come up and see my etchings rather than
do you want to have sex
why are threats so often veiled nice
story you got there would be a real
shame if something happened to it given
that the listener knows exactly what the
speaker had in mind it's not only anyone
is fooled by the charade but nonetheless
some aspect of the social relationship
seems to be preserved if the request is
slipped in between the lines I'm
interested in what that says about human
relationships about hypocrisy and taboo
also what it says about the kinds of
relationships we have like dominance
versus intimacy and commonality versus
exchange and reciprocity just to be
concrete why do you say I if you could
pass the salt that would be great well
in issuing an imperative you're kind of
changing the relationship you're turning
it into one of dominance you're saying
to a friend or to a stranger I'm going
to act as if I can boss you around and
presuppose your compliance you may not
want to move the relationship in that
direction at the same time you want the
damn salt so if you say if you could
pass the salt that would be great it's
such a non sequitur that the
intelligence of the listener can figure
out that it really is a request but both
of you know
you haven't actually turned the
relationship into a superior inferior I
think that's the key to understanding
all of these that the sexual overture
the veiled threat the veiled bribe and
so on are ways of preserving one of
several kinds of relationships at the
same time as we transact the business of
life such as requests such as sexual
overtures that might be inconsistent
with the relationship that we have with
the person so it's in a way using
language as a way of doing social
psychology
I'm also interested in the effective
memory on language why is so much
language metaphorical not in terms of
poetic ornamentation we don't even
realize that they're metaphorical if we
said say something like he moved the
meeting from three to four we're using
the metaphor of time as as a line as a
spatial dimension of a meeting as a
thing and rescheduling as causing motion
if we say I had to force myself to be
polite we're without realizing it using
a metaphor of our natural inclination as
inertia a change in inclination as the
application of force and indeed as
conflicting tendencies as different
objects or people inside our skull being
shoved around it's almost hard to find
an example of language that's not
metaphorical so what is the save of the
human mind does it say that we actually
can never think abstractly that deep
down we always have little cartoons in
our head of little Puck's being slid
around on the ice or or people shoving
each other inside the skull or does it
mean that we really do think abstractly
but that deep in the mists of history
when the first coiner of expressions
like force so and so to be nice or move
a meeting came about they needed some
kind of verbiage and so they cooked up a
metaphor on the spot better than saying
glorg you can say force because least
some people might have some chance of
knowing what you're talking about but
ever since we've been repeating the
metaphor dumbly and we really do think
abstractly that's an interesting
question about what makes us tick
inspired by language and I'd like to get
some insight into it
I did what I think is the isn't for a
long time will be the most exhaustive
study of one aspect of child language
development to the fact that kids make
errors like I we holdin the baby rabbits
and the alligator goat kerplunk where
they add a regular suffix like edy to an
irregular verb like hold or here or
stick producing errors like sticked and
tared and hold it I analyzed 20,000 of
those forms from computer transcripts of
children developing language and
developed a theory of why kids make that
error how they outgrow it and what it
shows about language the reason to
obsess over a tiny little topic like
that is that it's a nice illustration of
children's creativity in acquiring
language the the essence of language is
that you aren't restricted to a fixed
list of messages that you've memorized
and then you then regurgitate like a
parrot rather you you recreate me
combine elements to create new messages
every sentence that we utter is a brand
new sentence but it's rather hard to
study the process of kids making up new
sentences when a kid says something like
sticked or tared or hear it or hold it
it's a tiny example of recombination
that I think is the engine that powers
language as a whole the the the act of
children making an error like that I
think is a way of catching them in the
act of doing something that makes
language powerful namely combining
things by rules and in trying to
understand that one phenomenon I hope
that we my students and I shed light on
the process of linguistic generativity
or creativity in general I also tried
very hard to crack the code of what
verbs mean and how that influences how
we use them in sentences the verb is in
a way the chassis of the sentence once
you pick the verb
it's got slots that the rest of the
sentence is built around the subject the
object the indirect object prepositional
objects and so on so knowing how the
verb works tells you a lot about how the
sentence works and how the verb works
depends on what the verb means you might
think how could you ever get your get a
handle on something as nebulous as what
a verb means but but I'd like to think
that that I craft a lot of that code
what's the difference between a verb
like to fill in a verb like to pour and
a verb like to load they're not just
video images in the head of someone
pouring and filling and loading but
rather they have an Anatomy too built
out of parts parts like to cause to move
means versus end let versus for versus
cause
the idea that language works by an
interplay between memorized units that
we call words and rules for combining
them and that the reason that we have
language is that we are a species that
lives off social cooperation and
know-how and that language is an
evolutionary adaptation that multiplies
the power of technological know-how by
allowing us to share it and that allows
us to negotiate relationships so that is
a kind of a nutshell description of how
language works and why we have it I
think is not so obvious that it's it's
helpful for someone to to draw the
picture in such broad brushstrokes and I
like to think I've done the same or
helped to do something like that for
thee for the human mind what is how does
the mind work what is a human mind for
the idea that the mind is a system of
organs of computation that is
information processing subsystems that
evolved by natural selection to allow us
to figure out how the world works and
figure out how other people work as a
survival strategy for Homo sapiens is a
general idea but it does help to make
sense of the whole shebang and I think
it offers me some potential of a
satisfying answer as to why we have a
mind and what it does so both at the
microscopic end of how irregular verbs
work and why kids make errors on them
and the macroscopic view of what is
language what is the what is them
you